welche die welt nicht mehr wir reden
über high life dass der neue film von
jenni
sie haben uns angelogen sein fenster
typisch sie wussten es und er fängt da
an wo ist eine kubricks berühmtes 2001
odyssee im weltall auf wirklich und ein
baby
das kleine baby ist das töchterlein
robert pattinson und die beiden sind
erst mal die einzigen die wir sehen in
einem raumschiff sie geld mehr übrig
gebliebenen von einer expedition die
zwei aufgaben hat man sich hier nämlich
auf der einen seite ein rotierendes
schwarzes loch als ein kraftwerk zu
nutzen das kann man nach einer sache die
es wirklich gibt es der sohn des endlos
prozess das ist ein physikalischer
vorgang der viel zu kompliziert ist und
jetzt erklären der film macht ihn aber
sehr anschaulich navigare experimente
finden gerade im weltall hat zum tode
verurteilt werden als versuchskaninchen
benutzt dass sie zukommen werden
wir können nicht einmal kontakt zu ihnen
herstellen
ihre nachrichten und berichte wochen
jahre bis sie bei uns ankommt und das
zweite ist eine art zwischen experiment
denn alle leute die auf dieser position
sind sind sozusagen die pigs bzw
versuchs raten allerdings menschen die
nämlich auf der erde keinen richtigen
platz hatten weil sie ausgegrenzt
eingeschlossene zum beispiel
strafgefangene cobo sind die aber
plötzlich im all wo sie eigentlich
unendlich ist ein platz haben nämlich
auch dass ein raumschiff
sie haben uns angelogen sie wussten ist
sie wussten es und da fliegen sie also
in richtung kraftwerk risiken kennt
ärzte versuchen sich zu vermehren
das ist alles ganz furchtbar und
wahnsinnig toll zuständig für die
familie rey ist eine person die sich des
gatten mordes und des kinder abmurksen
schuldig gemacht hat die haben ja alle
irgendein dreck am stecken in diesem
raumschiff und das ist genau die mal
wieder die beste leistung ihrer karriere
liefert das wird auch langsam langweilig
es mit jedem neuen film seit man die
firma auf die zu übertreffen ich kann es
nicht mehr sehen
angeberei
in dem film geht es also um sex es geht
um tod und es geht vor allen dingen
etwas das man nur als science fiction
geschichte erzählen kann denn viele
verstehen der science fiction falsch als
etwas wenn man ein ganz normales auto
oder ein western als sonst was erzählt
aber ein paar raumschiffe dranhängt ein
paar robotern bei aliens hier geht es
aber darum dass diese zentrale metapher
nämlich dieses schwarze loch tatsächlich
ein bild ist dafür wie nah können wir an
die natur kommen wenn wir was von dir
wollen ohne dass uns auffrisst was
natürlich für die sexualität ganz
genauso gilt wie für die schwarzen
löcher und die leute spielen sich
wirklich die seele aus dem bleiben was
ist mit meiner bildung also mehr gas ist
dabei die sensationelle ist noch besser
als inspirierend ich bei gerader nino
war ganz ruhig raffen sie nicht als
notleidend was wachsen wird
hey benimm dich aber alle miteinander
reißen da einen film runter ich hab so
was lange nicht gesehen also einen
science fiction film der in seinem
science fiction heftigkeit so ernst
nimmt und dabei irgendwie nie sich ins
nordische verkrümelt der letzte der mir
so positiv ausgefallen ist dass sich der
sion sono hier sowieso bosch der iss
bringen star der flüstern wird stern er
war genauso gut aber ganz anders und
lange nicht so finster und da es im
weltall finster ist ist der von claire
denis nach netto besser ich reiße ich
sehe wie eine hexe
sie sind gern das wissen sie auch und
dann sollten den film noch leute
angucken die sich ihr leben lang gefragt
haben ob sie lieber ins theater gehen
sollen oder lieber irgendwas ganz großes
angucken sollen was viel größer ist als
das ja das geht nämlich beides auf
einmal
du kannst ein kammerspiel machen dass
gleich das gesamte universum da reinhold
wusste ich auch nicht
die chancen stehen nicht gut stimmt
schon aber wenn meine arbeit verbracht
ist wenn die perfektion erreicht es dann
was freiflug